so PI data welcome to PI data I'm sure
your you have second day day two of a
very hands-on conference I've heard hash
pirater DC 16 is trending so nice work
there thanks for having me here Brendon
and Adam and rest of the team and pi as
well as all of us know is is is quite
popular powerful into two two ways of
course on the math connotation and the
other connotation of Life of Pi so talk
about little of the boat but all the
culture as well as the numbers make big
difference algorithms + data is business
and today if you're going to think about
I mean but earliest books at once some
of us are adverse were was around around
how you use algorithms and create
programs it's simple programs there was
the earliest title we hijacked here but
most business today's run on data and
financial services from Wall Street
onward self trended s words algorithms
Adsense one of the largest money-making
machine out there is one hundred percent
algorithms running on data but these
transformations not come for simple they
come with people algorithms first data
plus people brings transformation it's
the teams that work together they
transform the entire companies that make
decisions using data which is brings
transformation data making data-driven
decision-making actually needs a lot of
courage oftentimes they actually come up
with completely counterintuitive
analysis and conclusions and people
acting on them still needs a lot of
courage and that's kind of what part of
the story the of the of the keynote
today will be how we use visual Indians
to kind of try to demonstrate the
interpretability of the analysis
transformation the data and AI is right
around the corner which means change is
coming in in loads and loads of change
time is our only non-renewable resource
and that's kind of what obviously
gravity is kind of which that we've been
asked to demonstrate but time truly is
only non-renewable resource I mean
everything else can be caught back
including cash but time will not be back
for us and so I go back to Bob who's
your time for you is worth saving now
it's time to act and start moving
towards using data and data science as
part of your applications code is
changing the world oftentimes run into
people who want to want to come and ask
for how can I do X what is the best way
to do y how do I bring big change in the
world and there's only two really big
ways to do the change one is to be
Deepak Chopra which it's not a mere feet
other other is to be software engineer
because software actually is touching so
many different spheres of life it's no
longer a programmer Spartan software is
eating the world which means we can
actually now go and change different
fields whether it's agriculture health
care insurance cards or just teaching
education bringing care and serving
communities is better than the software
and this community is open source
community Python community was also is
also a software movement and kudos to
dom focus and others are supporting the
vibrant community in python world but i
think communities and software
communities i have now become to bring
change to different vertical communities
I think that's the bigger transmission
happening in this space value has really
shifted to asset-light platforms what
does that really mean well Airbnb is
more valuable than Hyatt and health in
these days right and it has no physical
assets to it's it's it's
Capital same way as uber is more
valuable than Tesla right now that the
changes are thinking about what is being
more valued in terms of innovation your
brand and your community is what you're
building truly as a company and you're
defending your brand through to real
data products using your data forming
alliances with your data that what what
the data you have is some of the few as
a corporation most companies have data
today that is not available for Google
or Facebook that's the data you're using
to build alliances with other companies
of data and building well simple
beautiful data products that can
transform kind of your customers
experience that customer experience is
what you're truly making beautiful and
more more interactive to your core
platform and that's the core team behind
how vertical is from the truth new
horizontal in many ways a software is
eating your vertical of a as people are
digitizing your bigger business into
small lots of small micro businesses you
realize that software is a commodity
because code is truly a commodity
anything that is digitized will become
free so what I'm the net base value of
your business is going down so only we
can increase can continue to increase
value is to bring in data products that
are horizontals focus has shifted from
internal to more of an external
interactions how do you build an
ecosystem how do you have a PI data
conference even though your capital one
as a company and bringing community this
is an external interactions as opposed
to just pure product focus or focus on
yourself horrible meetups how do you how
do you create grass root movements
around ideas of the core business I
think that's going to be and then
spreading it to other horizontals that
the core team you're seeing how do you
give away resources for example which
means this is capital one is a
conference center is a resource that has
become available now for the pie
community which is quite a dramatic
difference from days before where you
would have to
lock in resources how do you go from
rule based systems to pattern
recognition systems that's another core
team of AI how do you go away how do you
look at outliers how do you work on
outliers are supposed to eliminating
them how do you not sample away the core
team behind your data I think those are
the kind of teams that you'll see with
AI they're rebuilding of big monolithic
applications there are rules based
applications to pattern recognition
based applications using deep learning
and machine learning microservice is not
just monolithic apps I think a large
part of monolithic apps are going to be
rebuilt in the next few years and that's
the dramatic so it's a tremendous this
kind of I would say change that's bigger
than even the y2k kind of change where
people are going to rewrite a ton of
traditional applications that are
thousands and thousands of rules whether
it's in insurance or health care or in
credit cards and and those applications
are going to be written in small small
services enterprises are reinventing
themselves as micro businesses and these
micro businesses are actually far more
valuable than even sometimes the bigger
businesses themselves so I think that's
something that you here's we are seeing
a lot is following the trends the micro
services of software you get building
micro businesses around them open source
then is another huge phenomenon software
and in open source we are seeing the
defense of community with product right
here supposed to difference to the
community with just pure philosophy its
code I think open source has truly made
this a pull based economy not a push
based economy how do you kind of its
it's open source not just about free
it's about freedom the freedom to be a
software maker not just software
consumer and I think that's kind of the
core team behind the change you're
seeing and how h2 itself in has been
adopted by thousands of organizations
with very little push a lot of Po and
that's truly because companies want to
make software not just consume it
becoming consumers to this such a
powerful phenomenon in our midst us is
is very limiting it's a participative
environment let's you be makers and
makers are going to make this kind of a
core team you see well among stitch
tours as well it's naturally in
community with beautiful product that's
kind of the core end goal of most data
science and data science becoming a
software movement means that you can
actually not build data products that
become AP ice that become applications
that users can touch and feel there's a
huge convergence of many fields
happening at our own this time that used
to be traditionally competing or even
unrelated you're seeing HR companies
trying to work on real estate prediction
of real estate values to to insurance
companies trying to make sure employees
take regular exercise so they don't get
get sick so it's lots of convergence
happening on this time and data is a
true horizontal that connects so many
different verticals what's the data
product so my task and it's the heart of
data product actually is of course data
but it's trying to build feedback loops
that makes data really shine how do you
create feedback loops in your apps and
of course algorithms between automatic
machine learning that's a major trend
happening in terms of data science
refinement to deep learning we are
seeing a lot of real data science
improvements from the core platforms but
data and connecting data to users and
connecting those use interactions as
feedback becomes a real loop that you
want to accelerate its that loop that's
learning continuously and that's the
core I mean of course you coach this
data product with an API or a user
experience but that's the heart of a
data product it's the learning rate that
defines how fast your application
getting smarter before your data driven
applications now your applications are
learning from data and so you no longer
programming your computer the computer
is learning from data and I think that's
pretty dramatic difference from how we
build applications in the year 2000
learning of course Wow learning of
course needs a lot of heart you need
love to learn a lot of hard work
learning is admitting that you did not
know something a minute ago and that's a
hard problem and that takes again a lot
of human human openness to learn new
things an example here is like for
example I remember speaking to the
author of Moneyball Michael Lewis and
then Oakland A's when abolished kind of
has got in behind how data science
became popular in baseball open when
they when he actually was in the locker
room of Oakland A's team he found that
nobody was even presentable none of the
players looked great on TV right and but
they were all good at what they were
doing very well individually and
together as well I think data science
throws at us analysis that will force us
to do things that don't look great on TV
or don't look great on traditional
metrics of hiring people or adding teams
and I think that's kind of the core team
is learning XLR of courage data science
it to a sense exactly the search for
truth because you're continuously
refining your hypothesis again and again
and challenging your own city school
about something and in many ways that
something is really you because data is
actually a footprint we have left on the
universe the universe like this
auditorium is very sparse and it's also
very messy just like a few minutes ago
nobody could predict that we'll all be
out of this auditorium so it is there is
[ __ ] capturing events in the universe and
so it's both sparse and messy so it's a
very compelling compelling footprint of
you on the in the world so you're really
trying to look at human behavior at our
behavior individually and together and
in conjunction with other events that
are kind of really sarcastic so data
science is really trying to get more
more of handle on the self
how did we build this thesis around what
are many aspects of the data science bar
well data it starts with data data comes
in many forms and factors sparse and
messy being other parts which we kind of
left on the left side of the equation
here with a core through the signs of
this is algorithms which is basically
speed and accuracy is what we are trying
to predict that accuracy and speed come
together in one package because you want
to predict whether tomorrow tomorrow's
weather today not day after so timing
this core aspect of finding the most
accurate prediction but also there's a
bunch of algorithms that have been
invented in this space have been built
some of itch itch to a hospital psych it
has build a bunch of them pandas open
source communities the our community the
spark community all these communities
have been building a lot of good
algorithms that can be used on large
data sets and that's going to the core
thesis here as you keep adding more
features for example if h2o we had to
rebuild the entire data platform do once
we cross the thousand column doesn't
feature barrier at 10,000 feature
barrier we had a more Colin are
compressed variable chunk data
structures to take advantage to take
advantage of this partners at ND more
brokenness off of the column structure
as you get a million columns you're
really looking at dots not columns
looking graphs the core data structure
got had to be reinvented to deal with
sparse data for text and images of
course deep learning the best the game
in town is deep learning which is pure
matrix multiplication and that's where
we've moved on to GPUs and traditional
non-traditional hardware I think that's
kind of the core ethos of how how the
whole space has been evolving but this
space is not interesting if this does if
it doesn't bring different dimensions
different people different walks of life
to the space and that's experience if
you can't reach the Excel using data
state analysts which is hundreds of
millions of people then you still not
solve the problem
it made it simple yet so I think a core
part of a large pot which 20 inventions
that are happening inside the company
are towards simplifying the space how do
we make it easy to operationalize it how
to be easy to deploy it but also how do
you make software designers use data
software designers use data science and
algorithms without having to
dramatically alter their application
structures an API is play a very big
role there well different frameworks for
API different design frameworks
improvements in d3 for example have
brought much more visual interpretation
into the core ethos of data science we
will talk a little bit more about
storytelling because that's such an
important aspect of increasing the
experience and increasing the bigger
number of people you can touch with your
data analysis people have seen this book
am imagining phenomenal book definitely
worth the read tried to pick a small
tidbit from it it'd be the Apgar score
before nineteen seventy a lot of people
actually the 50s is when Apgar score was
actually invented in spite of anecdotal
book and it infant mortality of such
rampant because it was very difficult to
find midwives were very well educated or
who could sense when a person should
when a newborn needs to be taken up to
given urgent care so Apgar a nurse came
up with this simple score and with just
adding those three different features
one can make an assessment whether to
take the newborn 22 to the doctor
urgently or not and that was a pretty
dramatic improvement worldwide so taking
fast things slow where if someone came
up with the learning behind on what are
these features and then given with a
simple way don't come up with a score
and that makes a huge difference in
changing the world's to learning and
scoring two different aspects of course
there's online learning which is truly
unsupervised learning
this another great book recommend score
takes care of itself trying to build
teams and how to build really powerful
teams that can deliver on results not
just deliver on how individuals are
individual rock stars are incentivized I
think the growing he tows you'll see the
data is a team sport in order to get a
lot of people to work together you need
to work like as if it's a game that you
planning to win and together not just
making one or two of our people heroes
and I think that's the core ethos that
this book captures on how to create hype
our teams the power love networks you
have one idea usually use that as very
common thesis and trying to have
roundtables as opposed to square tables
in offices if you have one idea you're
just reached by one person you create a
ability for several ideas to be shared
within the group it's chance to bring
infinity of ideas to work for in your
favor I ideas are the map in which you
can really look at the world in a very
different in a very really simplified
way almost the dimensionality reduction
happens because wisdom of many people
can be applied on the on the situation I
think that we're truly going towards the
infinity ideas because this we talked
about earlier how do you bring use
interaction so your data that you
started with has now enriched data that
you can then serve back as data product
simple example would be connect an
application to for end user interaction
suddenly have lots of behaviors that you
can capture and start predicting and
then sudden and the user is reacting to
the prediction and the power law of
networks is both being able to create
lots of user interactions so that you
can create a very rich data product
it's something that we've learned quite
a bit both as a start-up and as small
communities the the core theme is to
build eco systems not just product
someone was saying earlier today that
Hadoop is not just a product it's a
person echo system yes in spark just not
just park my go system fight on it's not
just a product it's a huge ecosystem and
I think on put on the base languages
have been built so many new newer richer
frameworks that have built even larger
ecosystems and larger value has been
derived it's not so what raising a
forest not just a tree data is a team
sport and I think the in that is behind
that it's really how do you bring domain
experts to help us look at the right
data set so fully cured right data sets
and bring data scientists to bear
through their algorithms to help build
freely design rich business applications
I think that's it at every every
Junction of that line and we have had
those people with those disciplines work
at h2o at every Junction of the line
there is fierce warfare and and this is
real warfare people have a lot of
disagreements the mathematicians don't
necessarily have a lot of respect for
software engineers and vice versa the
software engineers don't necessarily
have huge respect for the date engineers
and the domain scientists and the
business apps you're kind of bring
really very very different dimensions of
work into one small unit so it's a very
violent situation and beauty about
violence is actually that it does create
a lot of innovation but you need to be
able to put a lot of different people
together and have them work as a single
unit and that's a core team behind it as
team sport teams for scum all are
completely learnable but they're
definitely vary a lot of work culture in
this case is your co-founder you can
build build a culture that really looks
for the score the final end game and
looks at how we can go change things
that's that that's the core piece that
eggs and bonds team sports let's hitch
20 we looked at this question why make
once here when you make in 10 and anyway
it really truly to do that is to expose
as much data to the entire team as as is
available to me and I think that's
something that's very interesting is if
you start playing that I want to see the
forest for the tree there's a very
different aspect to the overall thesis
most of our team is exposed to the
entire board that as these sort of a
very it's compelling to see you we just
need to see how the experiment place out
one one day woke up with a much more
richer dream why about just why not
change to all that 10 great CEOs or
women thus changing at the top has a
much bigger impact so it's two is
actually what for about forty-eight
percent women at this point we're a
small company but we are still growing
in the same structure no time we're
building leaders at every level and
we're looking to build some amazing
culture there which can bring change in
spades every generation has to fight its
own revolution and cancer is one of
those problems that we see she's a very
powerful data problem and it's a very
very distributed prominent networks at
work against us and with us so I think
this is one problem that we definitely
want to bring a lot of attention from
both the math communities the data
communities and software engineering
community 40,000 a farm eyes fMRI
studies got invalidated a few months ago
because it was a bug in how the software
was reading the pictures that's 20 years
of brain research that's no longer valid
so many surgeries so many analysis that
could but might have to be redone
essentially i think the what-for start
facing us is that this the software
always has box see and in this but
occasionally two of the software's that
are used but actually open source
software always has bugs
and you'll have to rerun your
experiments so science which is data
science in that data science by the way
now applies to us we have industrialized
science at this point with the data
science and so for us to fish store the
data if you keep still the data open
data within the company open data and
outside the company open data I think
those are two different forms of being
able to rerun the experiments to to
change your hypothesis I think building
open data ecosystems and specifically in
open data diagnostic software something
isn't happening to get our hands really
into and try to make sure we bring
change to places where you can actually
have impact on lives data products can
save lives then it's kind of the core
piece and consumers we are being
consumers we can integrate very diverse
verticals and say this is my data I want
to understand how well I am based on all
the data that you guys are cluttered
store it a link this lot is one of the
last team over when I bring into this
topic is such a human endeavor
interpretation is far more valuable
sometimes in accuracy people are going
towards gray box models because you you
can actually interpret them versus
purely black box models I think that's
something that we're going we're trying
to put some more visual machine learning
aspects into the picture here's a very
popular example of course content a talk
without having having the backdrop of
the political scene behind us but I
think 538 or has definitely done a
phenomenal job in trying to put stories
together for a large data sometimes
running thousands of simulations and
then coming back with a simple analysis
that tells the story I think visual
tools are kind of really powerful for us
to understand what's going on at every
level data journalism in visual
intelligence starts where data science
ends when we started five years ago when
seven years even is looking at data
signs of the space
small space if you want to acquire the
most number of still underappreciated
talent in this world it will be data
journalists fires now data journalist so
they where data scientists are today and
of course what is the design this of
course is obsessed with data i would say
ninety nine percent data and one person
story right I put a hundred person there
a business unit leader on the other hand
is looking at 85 person data and at
least fifteen percent of storytelling
and as you go up the stack which
executives are mostly storytelling I
think that's the core team and of course
below the board is of course grandpa was
like a hundred percent storytelling
because that's where the grandchild is
listening to stories I think that
storytelling aspect is really key to get
your analysis be adopted by the
community around you ai is eating
software software has been eating the
world's dance and end of code has been
declared we did an experiment of using
deep learning one of my team on a
machine the audience the deep learning
for taking code fragments from our own
inch to a code and create a new curve
using the planning and it was nearly if
they've compiled and a nearly looked
like real human present code and these
are women of course you're building test
cases but but you're also building
algorithms using deep learning I think
the point where a i can write code is
not too far out and i think that's one
of the pieces that so far software
programmers made a lot of other people
jobless and i think it's about time AI
takes sweet revenge revenge and starts
writing code software that train to sell
the data that's manufacturing
intelligence here's another favorite
slide of mine which basically shows that
a domestic cat is actually faster than
Usain Bolt right and and I butterflies
actually faster than him as well what
does that say about how come we are
leading the world
we're leaving the world because of
intelligence so he is going to be very
disruptive AI is manufacturing
intelligence manufacturing pickling
brains of surgeons of of Engineers of
different variations of every kind so a
is going to intelligence if intense
dominates well actually take offense to
the word artificial in AI there's
nothing artificial about it its
intelligence the intelligence is going
to be very powerful and it it it has the
capacity to make us more human by taking
away a lot of the dredge treachery were
cut off and also some of the real
advance work out of our hands as well
there's a possibility that make it can
make it more human human beings of
course it's just a process the struggle
is a story and and I think in that
process is how we are discovering
ourselves in many ways and the I would
probably be a very powerful companion in
understanding the world and
understanding ourselves I live with
evident better lose yourself this is the
time you got this all the time you
haven't split thank you